quoth the raven i have a plan corvids
such as Ravens and crows are known for
their intelligence they've been seen in
the wild solving problems in
communicating now zoologist London's
University have discovered that Ravens
can plan for future events something
only previously seen in great apes like
humans and chimps using tests originally
devised to determine planning abilities
in great apes researchers evaluated a
bird's ability to plan even forgo
immediate treats for later better ones
in one experiment the Ravens learn to
use a tool to get food from a complex
container in the absence of the
container
the birds pick the right tool for an
array of objects and held onto it
waiting for the treats field puzzle box
to reappear the birds remembered which
tool they needed and chose it even if
they had to wait up to 17 hours to use
it showing that the animals could plan
for the future they also chose the tool
instead of an instant tree knowing there
was a superior one in the puzzle box
worth the wait these trials show that
Ravens are on par with Apes when it
comes to planning and Ravens have as
much self-control as a four-year-old
human child these results go against
previous arguments that say Corbett's
can only plan for the future by storing
food it turns out they can remember not
only where food is but what tool they
will eventually need to retrieve it
[Music]
[Music]